[Musique]
ce matin les reporters des chaînes infos
étaient nombreux à être déployé en
france pour couvrir le premier jour de
déconfinement et qui dit déconfinement
dans de nombreuses grandes villes du
transport en commun c'est dans les bus
les métros et autres tramways que ce
matin de nombreux envoyés spéciaux avait
décidé de faire leur duplex
tout le monde a son masque sur le nez
correctement mais sauf que voilà alors
que les places sont chères dans les
transports avec les mesures de
distanciation social demandé par le
gouvernement
beaucoup ont trouvé la présence de ces
journalistes totalement superflu on peut
aussi noter que quand le gouvernement
appelle à prendre les transports
uniquement en cas de nécessité chez bfm
tv il trouve judicieux d'aller dans la
ligne de métro la plus saturée
d'ile-de-france pour nous dire
effectivement il y ait du monde et bfm
qui commence ce reportage à 11 heures
dans les transports et qui constate
qu'il ya un peu de monde etc les gestes
barrières sont inspectés et ça passe en
boucle
mais quelle blague l'image du
journaliste de bfm tv au milieu d'une
foule compacte sur la ligne 13 du métro
parisien a particulièrement choqué les
internautes et la distanciation social
est tout bonnement impossible à
respecter dans cette rame de métro
beaucoup ses prises de risques de la
part de reporters sont totalement
inutiles et sensationnaliste quel
intérêt de commenter en direct depuis
une rame bondée les conditions de
circulation dans les transports des
images dont beaucoup d'internautes se
demande la réelle nécessité
journalistiques alors on va revoir
l'image qui a énormément choqué c'était
dès 6 heures du matin donc c'était les
journalistes qui est au taquet c'est
notamment le cas de la journaliste h les
chevaliers alors qu'elle est dans le
métro on remarque que la distanciation
social n'est pas respectée il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont son plein
regardez
oui la distanciation social est tout
bonnement impossible à respecter dans
cette rame de métro et les stickers que
pose est collée au sol paraissent bien
ridicule actuellement alors ses
passagers on ne peut pas leur en vouloir
parce que nous étions avec eux à la
station saint denis porte de paris sont
attendus ce métro 40 minutes il a eu 40
minutes de retard et ils nous disent
tous qu'ils n'avaient pas le choix
qu'ils sont 10 g de monter dedans parce
qu'ils doivent aller travailler et
qu'ils ne peuvent pas avoir plus de 40
minutes de retard pour aller travailler
alors la pauvre a déjà acheté c'est dur
ça allait faire ça 6h du matin ces choix
vous et je vous montrais l'image d'el
cid c'est nous c'est à peu près pareil
hein oui mais moi je comprends pas alors
les mêmes qui râlent à râleraient s'il
y'avait pas d'image apprend déambulent
au mali ils restent dans leur rédaction
bien au chaud ils voient pas la réalité
de terrain faudrait savoir un moment à
un journaliste c'est quoi c'est une
personne qui vient là où vous vous ne
pouvez pas aller pour vous délivrer
l'information il faut bien qu'elle la
vive la formation pour vous la délivrer
ils sont venus sur le terrain ils ont
regardé
ils ont de façon empirique expliquer ce
qui se passait donc voilà ils ont fait
leur métier journaliste alors oui on va
pas reprocher à quelqu'un qui est sous
les bombes en cire et d'être sous les
bombes en syrie pour a raconté qu'à des
bombes en syrie c'est la même chose
ils sont au front donc il explique on va
regarder les images de l'essayer
jean-michel n'est pas du tout d'accord
avec vous valez regard du masque vous le
voyez dans la rame
tout le monde a son masque sur le nez et
ensuite
siègent aussi ses loyers une ancienne
mais il reste encore la distanciation
sociale je suis actuellement posés sur
l'une de ses fameuses marque
vous voyez donc c'est métro qui sont
tout de même rempli avec un peu
difficile de tenir les distances de
sécurité
alors jean michel mettent pas d'accord
avec valérie non j'ai pas d'accord je
suis d'accord que les journalistes
doivent témoigner mon falla il ya des
caméras de sécurité dans le métro il
suffisamment pour pas envoyer quelqu'un
ne reporte prix ce qui s'affiche dans
métro avec son masque c'est un peu
ridicule c'est un peu gadget
et puis en plus tu rajoutes du monde un
endroit il ya déjà du monde et le
problème c'est qu'il est bon que tu
rajoutes du monde sait que c'est avec un
reportage dans le sud les inondations
est interroge quelqu'un qui inondait
qu'à ceux dont dix ans est difficile et
tu renverses de l'eau dans le salon de
personnes tous les jours il se presse
écrite alors on va voir regarder c'est
nous aussi paris a regardé ce matin elle
aurait voulu vous montrer le parcours
d'entrée 1 pour aller dans un métro
alors ça commence ici
ensuite on descend évidemment on se met
au chaud un 7 à 11 mais on arrive dans
ce métro ici donc avec d'autres agents
de sécurité des agents de sécurité et
qui ont continué bien un parcours très
précis afin de ne pas se croiser avec
également des marquages au sol un
maximum de marquage au sol il va falloir
s'y habituer
le masque c'est l'une des nouvelles
composantes de ce coronavirus quelques
inquiétudes sur les transports et
beaucoup d'inquiétude sur la reprise du
travail c'est l'une des composantes
essentielles ce matin on retourne voulu
ringard de corse et alors est ce que
vous comprenez le petit coup de gueule
de certains téléspectateurs qui disent
qu'ils n'ont pas aimé le comportement
des journalistes
oui oui je comprends coup de chapeau
pour ces journalistes qui sont sur le
pont qui mouillent la chemise
il faut savoir que généralement ce sont
les débutants on amène donc bravo à eux
se trouvent ça a vraiment bien et en
plus nous mêmes en tant que spectateur
on attend que ça de voir les images
c'est une situation inédite et la
situation inédite dispositif inédit
oui bonsoir c'est surtout pendant des
jours on les a montrés dans le métro
nous envoyer là on installe des scripts
de sécurité
on met du gel sur la tige etc etc il
mourut ce que man au moment où ça
démarre on le montre ravi du gel sur la
cm sur 20 vous avez deuxième sur les
petits jouent pas dans le confinement
en dehors de confinement oui et donc
brusquement le suivrai puis vont pas y
passer 15 heures la effectivement
répondre aussi bien fait de le faire
parce que c'est la vraie vie la vraie
vie c'est ça c'est un métro bondé alors
oui avec 35 minutes de retard parce
qu'il ya une fuite en amont à saint
thois avec travaux mais c'est c'est ça
qui va se passer on savait que ça allait
se passer comme ça on savait qu'ils
allaient avoir du monde moi je préfère
voir des images comme ça ou bfm ces news
elle si nous montre vraiment la réalité
plutôt que les images que j'ai vues le 8
mai jours fériés
regardez il ya un mec qui va s'asseoir
là un autre qui va s'asseoir là l'autre
il va s'asseoir porte de bagnolet le ta
porte des lilas c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe dans la vraie vie là ils
nous ont montré la vraie vie les gens
qui se plaignent ça c'est la vraie vingt
cinq ans ce genre d'information mois
voir ce qu'on pense les téléspectateurs
qui lui on n'a pas eu son archet
d'accord avec valve totalement avec
valérie benaïm est d'accord qu'il vient
d'arriver dans l'émission avait révélé
une qui fait son entrée dans l'émission
merci je kiffe 24%
je kiffe pas 76% moi j'étais plutôt du
côté de jean michel et je vois pas ce
qu'il dit sont d'accord sonne l'équipe
de tournage comme vous aviez dit
jean-michel et toi oui un métro c'est
juste pas 300 400 personnes prévu à
trois personnes changer oui mais ça va
rien changer trois règles extra plus
trois plus trois